- [Host] This is Peach Fuzz.
Pantone's 2024 Color of the Year.
It'll make headlines,
but we're not gonna talk
about it a lot in this video
because selling colors is not
how the company makes money.
It also doesn't make money selling paint
or color mixing machinery
or even color itself.
What Pantone sells is
something much more abstract,
a promise of uniformity
so that the color Peach
Fuzz looks the same,
whether it's printed out on
a billboard or a ceramic mug.
This whole idea
that you can sell consistency
is relatively new.
It's the brainchild of
this guy, Lawrence Herbert,
AKA, the king of color.
This is the economics of Pantone.
New Jersey, 1956.
Recently graduated chemistry
major Lawrence Herbert
joined a small printing
company called Pantone
as a part-time printer.
At the time, product
packaging was less consistent.
Now we're used to seeing products
come in identical packaging,
like all these blue Modelo boxes.
But Pantone's president says
"It didn't use to be that way,
"back when everything
was done over the phone."
- It's really difficult to say,
"Hey, that's a, it's kind
of like a cherry wrap,
"but not as bright, but
maybe slightly darker."
It is really hard to
actually convey that message.
- [Host] For example, see
these two camera boxes?
The yellow on the right
is brighter than the one on the left.
Kodak says customers
were more likely to buy
the lighter yellow boxes,
logically thinking that
the darker boxes were older
and therefore contained older film.
Customers didn't know that
the difference in color
was due to the fact that
the boxes were printed
at different factories.
Each of which mixed their
own versions of Kodak yellow.
Herbert recognized this was a problem
as he worked his way up
the ranks at Pantone,
he became known for his
expertise in color chemistry,
and when he bought the company in 1962,
he had an idea to change
it from a printing company
into something entirely different
that could solve Kodak's problems.
His team created a set of formulas,
so every factory printed the
packaging in the same color.
- For a lot of companies,
color is part of their brand identity.
There's Tiffany and they
have that specific blue,
and it's very important because we say,
"Oh, that's Tiffany Blue."
We see the box and we go, "Oh,
you got me a Tiffany ring."
- [Host] 67 years after
Herbert joined the company,
Pantone has developed these formulations
into over 10,000 colors,
- So no one actually owns color.
What we have is the IP of
the Pantone color system,
which is a collection of
colors that we have selected
for it's not just this beauty,
but it's reproducibility
across different formats.
- [Host] Matching colors across formats
is harder than it sounds,
but it's vital for companies.
- They may have a color in mind
that they want to make sure
that can be reproduced
across different materials
that they may be presented color,
whether it could be from
their clothing line,
all the way to the storefront,
all the way to the internet
representation on the website.
- [Host] So say a company
wanted the same color
on its packaging and its magazine ads,
the ink might look one way on cardboard
and another way on glossy paper.
So Pantone would have to provide
slightly different formulas
to make the colors look exactly the same.
For example, the cardboard
formula would be adjusted
to a matte, absorbent,
slightly textured surface,
while the formula for magazine paper
would be altered to account
for the shiny finish.
To ensure all colors look the same,
Pantone has a rigorous
quality control process.
The company uses a tool
called the Spectrophotometer
to compare the same color
on different surfaces.
So Pantone would analyze
reflected light from the materials
and generate a number
value based on that color.
Then they'd compare it to the number
for the color in their official index.
If the data doesn't match,
they'd have to reformulate.
- You know, basically someone's out there
checking these cards to
make sure that the fabric
that we've dyed are within a
certain Delta E difference,
meaning that it the color
is consistent one by one,
and it's highly, it has
to be highly accurate.
- [Host] Pantone has done color testing
for over 10,000 colors,
which it compiles into these Color Guides,
like this 1964 version,
which cover the whole gamut
or range of colors logged by the company.
There are dozens of different
versions of the guidebooks.
Some are even made specifically
for certain companies.
- About half of our revenue comes from the
physical Guides that we have.
Because there are so many
different formats of it.
- [Host] They can cost about $700
for this essentials kit
to about $9,000 for a set
of color display towers.
Pantone says the guidebooks
generate the most revenue.
It sells them to designers,
marketers, and artists annually.
Each year they're updated with new colors.
- Your book is exposed to
air and it can oxidize,
and then what you see in your book
can visually change when you look at it.
So then you won't accurately
know if that's the exact color
that you are looking for.
So for that reason, it is important
to keep getting fresh books
so that you can view them accurately.
- [Host] Pantone says the
other half of its revenue
comes from its consulting and licensing
and digital services businesses.
Universal Studios approached Pantone
for the 2015 movie "Minions",
asking them to make a new yellow.
It made this banana inspired hue
and standardized it for the franchise.
- Banana?
- Uh, Stuart? (foreign language)
- Banana!
- [Host] Companies can
trademark specific colors,
so you can't say, "Make and
sell your own competing products
"using Tiffany Blue,"
but when it comes to all the other colors
in Pantone's guidebooks.
- So those who get their
hands on the color,
of course they can use the color,
but when we're communicating colors
between different people,
and this is where the
Pantone IP comes into handy
because we can refer to a specific shade,
a hue of a color through its name.
- [Host] While the majority
of Pantone's revenue
comes from those branches,
it's well-known marketing campaign
might be what makes it a household name.
2024's Peach Fuzz is inspired
by warmth and healing.
A Pantone spokeswoman
said they anticipated
increased interest in
self-care in the next year,
which they felt the shade represented.
- We want to make sure that
our community of creatives
and designers,
you have a conversation
about color every year,
at least once a year.
- [Host] After nearly
five decades of ownership,
Lawrence Herbert's family sold
Pantone to X-Rite in 2007.
The company makes color measurement tools,
which helped to cement Pantone
status as a color authority.
Just five years later,
X-Rite was acquired by
the Danaher Corporation,
a life sciences and
technology conglomerate.
In October, Pantone and
X-Rite spun off from Danaher
with 11 other companies
into a newly traded company,
Veralto Corp.
While Lawrence Herbert
could have never predicted
Pantone's evolution.
His idea was a leap forward
for the marketing industry
and the world of color.
And as products advance
from physical to digital,
Pantone's scope will
have to keep evolving.
- When it comes to color,
we want to make sure that it's
always going to be consistent
no matter where you are,
whether it's in digital format
where we can continue to expand on that,
those products and services,
or in different types of physical format
to help by our customers and
clients find the right color
and be able to execute those colors
the way that they want it to be.
(whimsical music)